on va parler d'un autre texte du sénat
on va parler donc grillage mans le texte
était examinée au sénat hier pour en
parler va nous rejoindre christophe
gendry bon jean christophe merci d'être
avec nous directeur départemental dont
le loir et cher pour la nouvelle
république
et d'abord pour que cela soit clair pour
tout le monde alex et vous les
clairanencs qu'est-ce que l'engagement
alors l'engagement qu'est ce que c'est
je me suis un peu renseigné alors comme
son nom l indique c la multiplication
des grillages des clôtures dans les
espaces naturels dans les forêts ce sont
souvent des grillages qui sont installés
par des propriétaires privés qui ne
veulent pas avoir d' intrusion sur leurs
forêts sur leur propriété privée
notamment dans des intrusions en période
de chasse et un d'autres chasseurs qui
viendrait à chasser sur leurs terres et
puis également ils mettent des enclos
pour pouvoir chasser à l'intérieur c'est
ce qu'on appelle les enclos de chasse
mais le problème c'est que tous ces
grillages pose est bien des difficultés
à la faune et la flore pour se
développer dans ces espaces naturels et
puis ça concerne en particulier le
territoire de la sologne où il y a et
bien entre 3000 et 4000 km de grillage
dans les forêts de sologne
alors c'est une proposition de loi qui
est déposée par jean-noël cardoux
sénateurs les républicains du loiret et
jean-noël cardoux c'est le monsieur
chasse du sénat elle et président du
groupe d'études chasse et pêche au sénat
et il défend donc une certaine vision de
la chasse contre 7 en grillage mans des
forêts c'est à dire une vision de la
chasse qui quand même permettrait un
épanouissement de la faune et la flore
dans les espaces naturels et donc qui ne
déformerait pas le territoire alors
quelles mesures ils proposent tout
simplement d'interdire les clôtures
haute dans ces espaces naturels des
clôtures qui ne permettent pas le
passage des animaux donc c'est à dire
supérieurs à 1 mais devant ça s'est
terminé les remplacer par des clôtures
mieux intégrée à l'espace naturel et si
les propriétaires ne respecte pas ces
règles eh bien il encourt une peine de
trois ans de prison et de 150000 euros
damende donc la peine est lourde et puis
c'est aussi avec ce texte la fin à des
fameuses autres lots de chasse voilà on
ne pourra plus chasser
sur son petit terrain de dizaines
d'hectares avec son grillage voilà ça
c'est fini et justement puisque vous le
disais alex la question elle se pose
particulièrement du côté de la sologne
et on va y aller puisque quentin calmer
et jonathan du priait sont allés voir
comment ça se passe du côté de la
sologne en regard de
raymond louis le répète à l'envi il est
un amoureux de la sologne né ici il ne
reconnaît plus son territoire en cause
ces grillages qui pullulent autour de
grandes propriétés privées là à la base
il ya un petit grillage de qui monte à
70 cm de hauteur tout faire on y passe
même pour les petits doigts ya même plus
un hérisson qui passent ensuite y'a un
grillage d'un mètre que d'un mètre
trente environ ensuite à un muguet à
deux mètres et en os des barbelés là ici
on se connaît un peu dans une promenade
carcéral ici c'est honteux honteux de
voir ça depuis 1998 avec son association
raymond louis milite contre satan
brièvement un combat pour préserver les
chemins et les paysages cette région et
défendre également la libre circulation
des animaux sauvages on a pris des
photos une fois une biche a été prise
dans le grillage on a vu aussi des
chevreuils qui ont essayé de passer à
travers les mailles elle est plus grosse
maille le soleil est en train de mourir
elle est vraiment à la ghonim moi je
dirais même qu'elle est mort par rapport
à ce que j'ai connu autrefois il n'y a
plus rien qui poussa à cause de lui sur
nombre d'animaux dans les enclos cet
engagement s'accélère en sologne ici de
grands propriétaires clôture des
centaines d'hectares de forêts au motif
de la lutte contre les intrusions au
cours de notre reportage sur un chemin
rural en pleine forêt de gardes privés
viennent à notre rencontre
notre combat dérange beaucoup ses
propriétaires on est on est un peu la
bête noire nous qu'est ce qu'on vient
faire la une on les embête pas ce qu'ils
aimeraient mieux que les personnes qui
passent et pouvoir chasser librement ce
constat est partagé en sologne y compris
par les tenants d'une chasse classique
loin des enclos privé jean françois
bernardin vie au milieu d'une propriété
de 300 hectares sans enclos la grande
majorité des propriétaires et des fleurs
le soleil ne supporte pas son engagement
d'abord parce que ça défigure la sologne
et aussi parce que ça entraîne des modes
de chasse
qui sont à tout le moins contestable
chez lui il arbore quelques trophées des
bêtes tuées dans des circonstances dont
il se souvient parfaitement si je tue 35
sangliers comme c'est arrivé l'autre
jour par quelqu'un dans l'après midi que
ce que je vais vous raconter ouah c'est
des tas de viande quoi ça n'a aucun
strictement aucun intérêt et pour moi ça
condamne la chasse et ça donne une image
de la chasse qui est dramatique parmi
les principaux opposants au texte du
sénat il y à ces grands propriétaires
benjamin tranchant et l'héritier des
casinos tranchant installé depuis huit
ans en sologne il a fait clôturer sa
propriété une façon pour lui de se
prémunir des intrusions enfin des
exemples de canard à kiffer ficelage en
forêt qui vous pourrez bien en temps
réel tout ce qui peut se passer de
joueurs comme lui en créant les
intrusions et on craint surtout son
parle de chasse un accident de chasse
pour quelqu'un qui serait sur le
territoire qui devraient pas y être et
moi je peux pas dormir tranquillement
ayant des intrus constamment pendant la
période du brame pendant vingt d'époque
les gens malheureux monde chez vous sur
cette propriété privée benjamin
tranchant organise de grandes parties de
chasse avec ses invités il se défend de
toutes pratiques irresponsables donc en
fait selon les chats sont faits une
enceinte qui fait 50 cent
on est postée en elles ont eu peu
importe et après les rabatteurs vienne
vienne dans cette enceinte a exactement
pareil comme il est ouvert et ils
sauront pas des animaux et après dance
qui sort je vous autorise à tirer ça ou
pas intéressant
on sait pas open bar on tire n'importe
quoi benjamin tranchant revendique la
liberté de jouir comme il l'entend sa
propriété privée ils dénoncent les
attaques de ses opposants à toutes ces
associations qui dénoncent un certain
nombre de choses ne sont jamais venus
dans cette propriété dont khalfa elle
parle tout et n'importe quoi on marche
pas sur les ans sur les animaux c'est
l'éthique de la chasse et dire qu'on se
clôture pour la chasse c'est n'ont cessé
11 cloront structure à cause des
intrusions on se retrouve à devoir
chasse en mieux formés ce grand
propriétaire dénonce le texte du sénat
sur l'engagement parlant d'une
proposition de loi soviétique dans le
même temps de plus en plus de
propriétaires font poser des clôtures
pensant échapper aux mesures
contraignantes du texte écrit ça
aujourd'hui je vais là-bas enfin réagir
à une phrase qu'on a entendu au début de
ce reportage et ce monsieur qui dit
notre sologne est en train de mourir est
ce que c'est vraiment ça oui on est
jeune précision la cei s'étend sur trois
départements le loiret le loir-et-cher
et lüscher et je précise avant de
commencer que la proposition de loi de
jean et le cargo n'est pas la seule
puisque y en a une par département et
qui ont pitié que débuter leur est cher
désormais et maurice a également
françois corbier nous lisions qui élu
député dans le chien or là on a une
également parce que le problème est
évidemment il le même partout et on peut
parier sur une mosaïque de grillage d'un
ami rade
qui alors qui défigurent savait pas
forcément a surtout que les grillages
maintenant s'opposer de manière un peu
plus astucieux il fut un temps où
c'était au bord des routes aura des
chemins ils sont encore en retrait ils
sont parfois masquée par une végétation
qui pourrait porter à dessein donc tu
vois moi mais ils sont bien là et c'est
peut-être pas forcément visibles mais
pour les animaux cessé de sur les
obstacles c'est un labyrinthe j'y
reviens kylie qui les empêche de
ouais on va dans le reportage
arnaud je reviens vers vous évidemment
créé sa légende et on n'est pas du tout
dans une opposition entre chasseurs et
écologistes
le sujet c'est pas du tout à prouver sur
la soviétique comme derrière le monsieur
dans le reportage c'est une opposition
loi révolutionnaire c'est la révolution
française qui a aboli le droit
seigneurial de chasse et qu'il a ouvert
à tous les français donc on est dans
quelque chose qui est très français est
très symbolique et il a fait les
fédérations de chasseurs effectivement
locales sont tout à fait hostile aux
grillages parce que de fait il signifie
une privatisation une retour si on peut
dire à l'ancien régime c'est à dire une
privatisation de la chasse donc c'est
très mauvais pour la biodiversité
évidemment parce que les animaux se
reproduisent entre eux mais c'est aussi
très mauvais symboliquement
politiquement parce que les territoires
de chasse sont ouverts à tous c'est vrai
on a vu ces images extrêmement triste
d'animaux qui sont pris vraiment c'est
dramatique comme comme image mais ce que
je trouve incroyable c'est
incroyablement métaphorique au plan au
plan politique on a effectivement le
l'opposition entre la chasse plus
populaires en venir et puis une phase
plus élitaire un peu comme une sorte de
clivage gauche droite et puis on a la
deuxième dimension de la politique
française c'est dès qu'on parle de
clôture d'intrusion de diversité on voit
qu'on est tout de suite dans la deuxième
dimension de la politique française et
donc décidément vraiment ces questions
de deux périmètres de frontières de
fermeture d'ouverture sont vraiment un
gros marqueur de notre notre époque
ouais vous partager cette analyse que ça
aujourd'hui on est dans une opposition
entre chasse populaire et saas de grands
propriétaires finalement à laure chazeau
populaire oui les synthés banias s'est
jamais trop shouldice et vous protéger
de l'extérieur bon il faut savoir et je
trouve la luz y voit le temps référence
à la révolution française
tu as fait pertinente
grillagée de grandes superficies c'est
s'accaparer les ressources dans le
gibier qui est juriste c'est à dire
qu'il n'appartient
qu'aux privés sur le territoire il se
trouve effectivement ma culture et ses
s'accaparer les ressources et
faut pas non plus n'est pas dit qu'un
aux prix du sag
de spens et se négocie autour de dix et
quinze mille euros l'hectare ces deux
fois lecteur de moss pour péter 300
hectares c'est déjà pas à la portée des
plus pauvres il faut bien savoir que je
sais pas si on peut dire entre et erwin
est certaine manière je dirais plutôt
entre ceux qui ont l'éthique de la
chasse à ceux qui ne l'ont pas parce que
je dis c'était très bien dit dans le
reportage la chasse c'est l'émotion la
chasse et la quête cetud c'est un match
entre l'animal et les chasseurs 6,6
après le match il a été payé d'avancé ça
devient l'abattage mais ça n'a aucun
intérêt
c'est une question
des classes entre cuba s'est tue c'est
une question d'éthique si il ya
également de grands états qui ne sont
brèves ou nous l'avait dit il ya
plusieurs textes qui sont sur ce sujet
ce qu'on sologne c'est une question
politique il en a été question notamment
durant la campagne des régionales de ce
sujet de l'engagement est ce que c'est
une question politique comment le vivent
les élus et comment le vivent les
habitants je vais vous dire ils sont
assez attentiste parce que c'était un
serpent de mer ça fait des années et des
années qu'on en parle vous l'avez bien
haut prélat vous pour les trois quatre
mille nous qui le mène de grillage on
serait plutôt entre quatre et cinq mille
ça se poursuit des grillages qui sont
posées tous les jours qu'ils sont les
plus hermétiques que sur les autoroutes
gibier qui arrive à rentrer sur
l'autoroute certains arrivent à sortir
des parcs il n'ya pas dire que les parcs
on va dire cloud est cerné un
basculement est certes un grillage on va
dire faire rentrer les animaux sur une
propriété des bornes jeetoo clore une
culture sur deux ou trois pans notamment
pour embêter votre voisin et puis vous
mettiez ligne de tir sur la partie n'ont
pas pu y aurait pas ça permet aussi de
voir de près les facilement les animaux
les gens sont un petit peu du pain il ya
une forte opposition ça c'est clair il
une manifestation armenta récemment
mais on dire ça ça fait tellement
longtemps que c'est sur la table qui ne
se passe rien à faire à
des gens très puissants voilà on n'est
plus là malheureusement parce que
c'était un homme respectable mais bon il
ya d'assaut en son temps avec un bémol
on va dire des derniers hauts placés et
lui aussi été conservé on a au moins les
gens se demandent vraiment est ce que ça
peut bouger ce qui aurait une volonté
politique au plus haut niveau pour que
ça bouge pour l'instant vous dit peut
être clair les tests ont cédé le sénat
c'est pas du coran interdit mais c'est
quand même l'assemblée nationale là où
vous l'avez dit auparavant qu'elle
pouvait ne rien se passer est ce que ce
texte a fait un véritable légende et le
cardio ou est-ce qu'il va y rester
lettre morte
bon il ya un petit peu de doutes et
d'attendre merci beaucoup merci cressard
gendry d'avoir été avec nous un
directeur départemental du loir et cher
pour la nouvelle république pour nous
éclairer bien évidemment sur cette
question qui se pose particulièrement du
côté de la sologne merci d'avoir été
avec nous
[Musique]